(audience applauds)
- All right it's always
nice to end the hour
with something that brings a little joy.
I feel like this whole
episode has brought some joy,
but whatever, this is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music) (audience applauds)
Usually when someone
graduates from college,
there's a lot of family
fanfare and celebration,
but when Texas grad Ashley got her degree,
there was even more for
the family to celebrate.
Both her mom and dad got
their degrees as well
at the same university on the
same day, which is so cool.
(audience applauds)
It marked a first in Texas
Lutheran University's history,
we have all these degree
holders on the line right now
watching on WOAI in Texas.
Say hi to Ashley and her mama and daddy,
Robin and Greg, everybody.
(audience applauds)
- Hi y'all.
- I mean, I guess I'll
start with you, Greg.
Like, first of all, thank
you for your service.
You were in the military,
right, thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
But is that the reason
you ended up going back
to college 'cause you got outta service
and you were like, maybe I should finish,
maybe what I wanted to
do in the first place
is that one of the reasons?
- So I started college
right after high school
and quickly realized that that
wasn't what I wanted to do.
I joined the Army, spent 22 years there.
After retiring in 2017,
I decided I was either going back to work
or we were going back to school.
Robin wasn't too excited
about the we part,
but she came around and
eventually we ended up at
Texas Lutheran University.
- Oh, that's incredible.
So what I mean, Ashley, how
was that going to school
like with your parents
and graduating with your parents?
That's incredibly cool.
- It was.
It was really awesome.
They asked me permission first (all laugh)
so they made sure it was okay.
And I had been in college
for a year and I had nothing
but great things to say about
Texas Lutheran University.
So I was just so excited to
share that experience with them
and to see them come
to a four year college.
It was just so exciting.
I was just so proud.
- Yeah, it's such a great
thing for just an inspiration
for a lot of people who wanna go back
and just feel like, well,
maybe I missed the opportunity.
You know?
And you never have.
You can always go back.
So what was graduation day like?
- First of all, I was trying
to prepare not to fall,
while walking the stage.
And so after that I
was able to turn around
and it was very surreal
watching my husband
and daughter, you know,
walk the stage after me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was very touching.
- Yeah.
Well, thank you guys so much.
This is the coolest story.
(audience applauds)
I don't think I've ever
heard of anything like this
happening, but Greg and Robin,
and I'm liking your post right now,
but that's not all our season long partner
pilot pen makers of Frixtion,
the go-to erasable pen
and the Kelly Clarkson
Show want to celebrate
people like you fearlessly
chasing your dreams
and inspiring everybody in the meanwhile.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience applauds)
Congratulations to all of you.
That is so super cool.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Dionne Warwick, Damon Elliot, Mikey Day,
Ivan Marrero, Blake, and Logan.
After the break, if it's
not, try and change it.
(audience applauds)